it's interesting because you know you've
always been somebody through music who's
who's communicated an array of things
and sometimes I wonder when you write
music do you ever have to explain it to
people like do you after have to go
carry you know I wrote this one song or
do you ever have to hide out on him I
don't think he's actually listening
single word I've said in 16 years you
know I kind of wish he did pay more
attention to the lyrics I'm sure he does
I don't think so although we were broken
up and he came to do this so what video
and I didn't want him to know I was
calling him a tool cuz I thought maybe
he'd leave so I was like so Dave Myers
did the video with me and I was like
Dave play line three then skipped a line
five definitely do not play a line 10
he's like you want to do this piecemeal
I was like we have to cuz he can't know
all these names I'm calling him so that
was one time I thought he might be
paying attention um I think he's
flattered but yeah so misunderstood I
did and I wrote all these like all my
pre teen angst came out and just all the
just the pain that had been living
inside of me and then every interview I
had to explain myself more and more and
more and it started to be just
overwhelming it was just it was like two
hours of therapy every day it was just
too much was it yeah what do you get I
mean your relationship to me is
something that's amazing because you've
always been honest and raw about it and
I'm wondering when you go through that
with somebody you go through thick and
thin you know you land on the other side
what does that mean for that there is no
other side you don't land
[Laughter]
there's just smooth waters and not
smooth waters but that's it that's
what's great about I love I mean I have
a lot of friends that jump from
relationship to relationship because
they love the butterflies and they they
want to be courted and they want to they
want it to be new and I understand that
I get that nothing feels better than
getting to falling in love with somebody
for the first time and getting to know
their body and just the whole thing but
for me I
I'm a creature of habit I love looking
at my history in the face of him mm-hmm
and when he says remember that one time
and it's like a 12 year ago memory I
love that mm-hmm that's what makes it
worth it to me you say plus date right
now I'll be terrible tell me about
yourself this would be dating apps you
don't want to be out there I got him on
a relationship mountain and Barbies you
said you turn into someone you swear you
would never be yeah that lyric really
stuck out to me because I think that all
that happened how so and who was that
person because I used to be so wild and
just carefree and just no mortality just
balls to the wall and now I'm I lock my
doors and I I worry and I'm a parent
very responsibly and sounds like who are
you so I've just I've just become a lot
more responsible than I would have liked
yeah
does that come from being a parent is
that I think it comes from caring about
your life and having things you don't
want to lose so yeah being a parent is a
huge part of that I think it's also just
I mean how many tables can you dance on
and underneath times he get arrested
where they keep you for good you're like
I'm never getting out sorry mom
so did you write this album while you're
pregnant some of it yeah some of it yeah
what was what's that like very sober I
remember it no um it's your how all the
feels so many feelings when you're
pregnant so it's it's actually really
easy to write a song I wrote perfect
when I was pregnant and raise your glass
I was pregnant with willow and this time
your voice changes a little bit too I
think I think my voice got clearer I I
perform or performed I recorded you get
my love when I was pregnant and I think
it's a great song I'll probably never
sing that way
again it's probably the best vocal I've
ever done in my life sounds incredible
maybe all down to Jameson wasn't much
room but all this had to come out how
did the song with Eminem come about I
loved Eminem I always have I think he's
a lyrical genius and I wrote him an
email and professed my love to him as I
always do really yeah classic I love you
I've always loved you I love that you
work with the same people over and over
again and like Rihanna she's hotter than
me but I'm funnier so you have to do
song with me and he just wrote back okay
that's it okay and what about the
butterflies when you go to work with
someone that you've been wanting so I
know it's done like this our fourth song
together with Eminem what other ones I
did won't back down on my record and
then or was that on his record I don't
remember yeah and then was that his
record and then what was the one on mine
I didn't know you were my last record he
was on here comes the weekend thank you
so maybe is our third song oh so now
it's familiar territory for you I just
love him yeah I just love him is he as
impressive in the studio as he is on
we've never been in the studio together
he sends them to me I'm waiting for the
supply purse it's so much fun that's
even better